- But let's get to our
first guest, everybody.
Like my American Song Contest
friend and co-host Snoop Dog,
she was raised in Long
Beach, California as well.
She went on to become
one of the most popular
actresses of our time.
She's also a mother, an environmentalist,
and the creator of Avaline wine.
I like a girl who makes wine.
Say hello to Cameron Diaz.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Is this Zoom?
- This is zoom.
You are now my official favorite person
to come on this show.
You just full on, I was
like, oh my God, it's Zoom.
- It's just zoom.
That's what it is forever.
- This is what I looked like forever.
- Right?
- Yeah.
I had like yoga pants that I did not,
you do yoga, I don't.
I just wore them and I wore tennis shoes.
And then I had like a pretty blouse.
- Yeah.
That's what it's about.
You're just like, okay, I'm presentable.
- I love it.
- But why would I do anything else
but other than this?
Why?
There's no reason for it.
- Once you've seen it.
My favorite was people would be like, oh
just 'cause it's a pandemic
to, oh this is what pandemic did to me,
I'm like this is like a
Thursday in 2018 for me.
I'm like, this is yeah,
totally, it's COVID,
that's what it was.